a reject nation Greg Alba here John
we're gonna watch the trailer for the JJ
Abrams produced flick Oh guys before we
hop into this I want to give a patient
the day shout out to a fairly new patron
we have at the patronage xhj one of the
quotes that I could read from this guy
of when we were messaging each other is
he enjoys creating products
he loves problem solving to give fit
stressful but fun well dude I got a
problem I don't know what the J stands
for I asked you and I don't like these
mystery answers I like to know who's
pledged to our patreon at all times
based off what we talked about how you
were sick of living in the dirty south
and I live in San Francisco I'm going to
assume your name does mean Jehovah you
mean Jesus giving Geppetto
Kanoe for all I know you could be
someone evil you could be someone
sinister regardless
whilst loose up the pledge at the end of
every month so appreciate your time
buddy
and by the way over at our patreon we do
full like TV show reactions weekly Q&A s
and music video coverage so you can go
check us out over there a bunch of
reward tips
[Music]
three months ago house grass in my front
yard
hey mailman shows up with the letter
from the Army I'm here
no idea why would I know
[Music]
down right there Wow answers yes sir
that white Russell
it's Caruso's kid right yeah there's all
these fullness
what's inside that compound like Call of
Duty Wasabi's the real thing
[Music]
oh that's not yet what do you do with
those people that's never good
I wonder how many people are thinking
this is linked to the Cloverfield
universe at this point if JJ Abrams name
is on it I just wouldn't put it past
whatever to relate in some minor way now
in some ways I kind of love this trailer
it's the super expensive version of a
generic b-movie flop head snow and yeah
this could be a really cool sort of
zombie revival phase we can kind of get
into like they recently announced zombie
land - gonna be like past ten years by
the time that movie comes out that
zombie phases really die down a lot but
it has died down enough that it should
come back yet these things take a lot
longer to really reclaim their Thrones
right now I feel like we're kind of over
it with the zombies yeah no I agree
this looks like a very fresh spin on it
I think this has been done before
obviously like I said in like B movie
territory this really had me going that
this is just a war film and then when
the zombie part got introduced I was
like whoa this this looks insane
yeah because I looked up what movie I
was like okay Nazis and World War 2
zombies and stuff
okay so then when the trailer started I
was like oh we're you know there was a
little more World War 2 that I was
expecting doing some of the thumbnails
myself I've always wanted to do
something like this so in that regard
this is pretty exciting to me I kind of
expected to see more from this trailer I
guess like not only a whole lot to it in
here about this movie - like five
minutes before we watch the truth I know
exactly I guess more from the movie this
felt like really contained for what it
is I don't know I don't know what why
exactly but I was like okay you do like
the parachuting sequence which is really
cool really intense very modern very
edgy and Morrow ish actually yeah and
then you have mostly just like that lab
I mean to me it's the first trailer so
that they're gonna reveal too much you
know for a JJ Abrams produced film which
usually doesn't have that kind of song
to complement its trailer to have Thor -
this rock and roll vibe of like crazy
fun action
horror is very different than what you
usually get when you slap JJ Abrams name
on the trailer so I think part of it I
think keeping it a little contained and
not showing too much of the film is very
much
Abram style except I think with the tone
that the trailer was giving you you'd
probably expect a little bit more
imagery that's a great way to put it but
I think with Abrams behind it he's gonna
be very careful like no we still can't
reveal too much though we gotta leave a
mystery element here my name is going on
this definitely gave me a sort of
Resident Evil vibe to with what's in the
syringe man like what's it gonna are you
mutating I think it's kind of refreshing
to see the cool horror movie
cinematography but if it has more of
this fun crazy tone I think this would
be a film that a lot of people walk away
from going that was an entertaining Lee
damn good time but yeah Wyatt rustling
here I saw that episode of Black Mirror
he was in that terrifying episode a
really scary episode maybe he's going
into the horror thing just like his dad
did with carpenters action horror path
now too like carpenter totally possible
and this directors only done one other
features so I like the JJ seems to be
taking chances and giving these guys a
shot at least even though like the war
sequences look CGI this stuff with the
zombies looks really creepy and
effective like I like that image that
they have with the girls like
decapitated head and then even the do
the you know the face being torn off
who's smiling at the end which I'm
assuming might be like one of his
signature shots at the trailer that
looks really good this could work or
this could be that like Abraham Lincoln
vampire hunter problem exactly where
like sounds super fun and awesome in
theory I feel like these movies have a
more deceptively tricky to hit tone than
you would think yeah you really do need
the right blend of enough war movie
elements to really feel like an
immersive war movie but also like you
said enough fun to where it kind of
justifies this weird pulpy b-movie
premise that we're getting into you know
I think you could do it it looks like
they're doing it especially with that
music cue and all that yeah like they're
there
in that direction which you know I like
I said I've wanted to make something
kind of like this for a long time so I
hope they nail it I'm very much
intrigued I didn't know about this until
the drop which is most JJ material all
right guys well what she's doing at this
trailer man what's your favorite zombie
movie let us know in the comments below
I think anything that stars Bruce Willis
in the last 10 years you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell to subscribe
buttons are broken hey check us out on
patreon we got full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is music video
coverage would love to have you become a
patron eject today